that's the end of that
hello folks hey guys welcome to rational
science we're here with my son ANS
you're going to talk about the muon
today whatever that is why are we
talking about the muon uh I think it
reminds me of cows you know like
whatever anyways let's uh get in there
with a little bit of Extinction what
Extinction oh that's coming later oh
[ __ ] and uh what is uh extinction
extinction on this channel right what we
say is that
we
are likely very likely the last
generation of humans on Earth
it all ends here okay and I've been
talking lately about a very popular
topic which is recession
we have
um a recession coming up and here's a
bit of news on that okay it says market
watch we see major stock markets
plunging 25 from Level somewhat above
today's that's by the Deutsche Monk and
they say that uh you know the United
States is expected to go into a
recession by mid 2023
so if you've got something better to do
well uh don't do it
wait for Mid 2023 maybe come sooner
maybe you don't have to wait that long
here's a tick tocker who uh apparently
got some people riled up because he
suggested that uh also recessions coming
around and more than a million people
locked into him and here it is says
um he says you should be terrified a
tick Docker went viral for explaining
why anyone in the U.S making less than
25 dollars an hour is in serious trouble
okay and uh the uh reporter the uh
person who wrote the piece says you know
it's time to be scared when a
tick-tocker says so
and so what does this person say he says
well recession looks more and more
likely lasting through most of 2023
inflation is rising along with interest
rates and more and more Americans
continue to find themselves in dire
Financial Straits and he goes on making
an analysis of uh regular expenses and
he totaled them to about 3 300 bucks per
month she says that you would need a
minimum of 20 50 almost 21 dollars per
hour and if you add taxes and other
expenses that would reach somewhere
around 25 bucks
and so he said you have to increase your
income
it's a must real average hourly earnings
uh fell 2.8 percent from October 2021
unemployment is up uh 3.7 for October
and uh he says working side hustles
isn't going to create enough income it's
going to have to be what investing
you're going to have to invest your
money uh probably in Bitcoin probably in
some stock market money or whatever uh
somewhere you're going to have to invest
and there's people who opposed what this
fellow says but even they uh these are
the suggestions they uh counter
suggestion I guess you could say they uh
proposed to him find at least uh one
roommate to uh cut costs in half or sell
that car that you can't afford
and these are simply periods in your
life that you need to get through on
your path to what Financial Freedom
right and I like that final note that
these people said it says this is a
season of your life but it's not a life
sentence I like that term Financial
Freedom that gets thrown around a lot
well I was focusing more on what this
these people said it's not a life
sentence uh meaning you know is the
recession
uh forever or will we come back that's
that's the issue it's going to last a
while the question is will we come back
or up if you wish or will we go down
into something worse like depression
aren't they like professionally
obligated to say that it will come back
well it's it's good for morale that's
what I'm saying like who is gonna go out
and be like no we're all gonna die
me but like yeah exactly
I'm not a pessimist okay I'm just a
realistic okay and so
um uh this is uh what the markets uh
another uh note up there another bit of
information says many investors are
betting on inflation peak in other words
that we're coming back here's why a
former hedge fund manager says they're
wrong okay and what he says essentially
is that uh investors are investing in
long
um long dated uh
bonds and you can see there at the
bottom says long-term rates of Interest
drop uh beneath brief time period
charges in other words he's saying that
the investors are investing in bonds
long-term bonds and that suggests that
at least either they're playing safe or
that they actually believe that the
recession is going to last a long time
it's going to last a little longer than
2023 because some of these people are
talking about at least two-year bonds
making it past 2024. so you may have to
be ready for a long-term recession okay
and uh another bit of news that kind of
uh points in that direction or shows
that we have some kind of problem uh but
partly because of this war in Ukraine is
that you know the Russians are now
changing dollars for yuan's okay so uh
the Chinese are happy they're saying hey
we're going from the Greenback to the
red back okay and so keep that in mind
that you know uh a lot of stuff is
changing in the world and it may not
favor the West
um it's just a wait and see him find out
what happens in the future but right now
we have recession coming around we have
oil problems energy problems and we have
major shuffles in the world economy like
you know Russia and some other countries
going into bricks another coin there and
uh yeah be all right because it's
they're called breaks because it's
Brazil Russia
[Music]
it just sounds like a funny currency
yeah it's the how many breaks do you
have yeah I guess the initials of every
country there that is a member anyways
uh these are the possibilities as far as
I'm concerned okay we go from recession
to depression and maybe to Extinction
okay the question is whether this is the
last recession okay but for that we need
to understand what a recession is the
definition we find is negative economic
growth for two consecutive quarters now
that that's a definition that the
British have and it's also an old
definition that economists in the U.S
had today they don't want to put numbers
to that like time frames so this two
consecutive quarters is an informal
definition the formal definition is just
negative economic growth without
specifying for how long the issue is
that you know we look at depression
which is the next step if it things get
worse it is it's defined as a steep and
sustained drop in economic activity
featuring high unemployment and negative
GDP growth in other words they haven't
said anything new uh it's the same thing
as a recession uh one thing's about
depression as longer and steeper that's
all that's the only difference but other
than that there's really no difference
between these two definitions and again
they may not want to Define them
perfectly well because you know it might
uh discourage people anyway I even use
the word depression anymore uh well no
because it has to stay away from that
one it hasn't had happened in a long
time yeah but I mean even if a recession
lasted two years they wouldn't call it a
depression instead of yeah
or yeah it's just for depression
just a long recession recession that's
all it is anyways uh we look at the
background Extinction what is it I say
these are my definition they're the
dying out of a species and mass
extinction The Disappearance of a food
chain and the question is whether we're
gonna disappear uh
with this uh collapse of the global
economy which is what I think is going
to happen Okay that's my theory okay and
based on the fact that all species in
the past that died in a mass extinction
died when the economy collapsed and I
don't see any difference now for for
humans and there's something and that's
something we can't do much about we got
brains though oh yeah but not brings it
up to fix the economy I can't fix it
anyways uh one fellow says put a comment
says uh the economy is going to burn
don't uh don't you think it's a bit
artificially contrived in other words
he's saying whether the people upstairs
you know the
um
Illuminati the New World Order folks the
people who are in the world the people
who have money and influence uh are they
uh planning something is this master
being masterminded or something you know
without lockdown uh policies and green
policies and Klaus Schwab Shenanigans I
don't see how the eradication of global
extreme poverty would be reversing I
don't see it reversing either so uh you
know I'm in the same boat as you are I
can't imagine how we can turn this
around okay I'm not sure what what we
can do to solve it yeah
um so what I look at is mass extinction
uh and question there is that you know
nobody has really defined the term mass
extinction or background extension for
that matter here are the definitions you
find out there for mass extinction uh we
this comes from the Wikipedia did they
find those yet yeah no they did and
you'll see in a minute here mass
extinction also known as Extinction
event or biotic crisis a widespread and
Rapid decrease in the biodiversity on
Earth
is that what an Extinction is a decrease
in biodiversity that's one way to put it
it's not I mean hopefully Extinction
means someone disappeared completely not
that there's a decrease yeah a decrease
in biodiversity there's one less
diversity no no because we're talking
about mass extinction yeah so massive
balls many we're not talking about one
species well still the the definition
still applies decrease in biodiversity
there's less differences
I disagree with you my dear son anyways
such an event is identified by a sharp
change in the diversity and abundance of
multicellular uh organisms it occurs
when the rate of Extinction increases
with respect to the background
Extinction rate and the rate of
speciation these people talk about rates
okay it sounds like mathematicians
talking and not about uh paleontologists
which are supposed to be uh qualitative
they're supposed to tell us what an
Extinction is and how it happens and
these people are defining things as far
as I'm concerned where it doesn't
address Extinction I mean the dinosaurs
are not around anymore was that because
there was a decrease in biodiversity or
is it because they Disappear Completely
they died it's binary is there still one
T-Rex walking around or not
so I call mass extinction The
Disappearance of a food chain that's the
mass right background would be uh this
The Disappearance of one species
okay anyways you can see here that uh
right at the bottom there uh you know
just look at one example Cretaceous
there about 145 to 65 million years ago
dinosaurs are no longer around and I'm
saying that the definition that we have
the official definition decrease in
biodiversity does not address what
happened exactly it or somewhere around
65 million years ago yeah uh if we're
talking about decrease in speciation if
we're talking about decrease in quantity
that happened through uh in the last
maybe million years or more
of the Cretaceous so it's not like you
know everything died on one day it's
like it slowly decreased until it the
decrease was incremental was uh
exponential and then they finally were
wiped out hopefully we talk about a
extension has to be defined in such a
way that we address the fact that some
species are no longer around and not
just saying oh it's a decrease in
speciation or quantity or whatever yeah
I'm wondering why they Define it so
vaguely like what Fringe cases did they
have to include in that definition well
here you think it's last
oh I know why one reason might be
because it's hard to tell where one
species ends and the next one begins
that's when they have to say loss and
biodiver they can't just say when the
last dinosaur or when the last T-Rex
dies because then there's T-Rex a and
T-Rex B and they're like close to each
other but when do you say the last one
died because the this one that looks
kind of like him might still be walking
around well uh again you wouldn't say
that any dinosaurs uh survive Beyond
around 65 million years ago there must
have been one last dinosaur or sometime
in the history of Earth we don't know
who that guy was but there had to be
that situation but again they might be
saying like like some of those dinosaurs
just turned into newer species no but
that's that kind of stuff but that's
what I'm saying they had to Define it in
such a all-encompassing way
they can't just say when when a species
ends because where does one species end
and the next one begin well I think it's
very clear we don't have any mammal like
reptiles from the Permian here we don't
have any
uh archosaurus from the Triassic we
don't have any dinosaurs from either the
Jurassic or the Cretaceous and not only
we're not only talking about these
animals which are very more or less
familiar to us we're looking at also the
plants you know the plants that died
they disappeared they're no longer
around so I think when we talk about
Extinction we can't just talk about oh
it's a gradual process where there's a
decrease in diversity or quantity you
have to go and say look it's The
Disappearance of something that's an
extension yeah okay but but they also go
back in time and study it like frame by
frame so for that time they weren't
extinct yet
you know here today we can say they all
they're all extinct that's easy but
they're also looking at it with the eyes
of the past where if you're looking at
it from the Cameron Point some of them
are extinct and some of them aren't
extinct yet but you can't just say all
this whole species died because they
might have turned into a different one
so did they go extinct or is it just
loss of biodiversity like
again I think they had to Define it in
very vague terms because of these Fringe
cases but because they did that uh they
don't zero in on the issue which is
which is the causes because they say oh
they just continued rolling and they
just branched out instead of you know
maybe a branch of the dinosaurs became
the mammals maybe that's what they have
in the back of their minds or something
along those lines and so it's like we we
never talk about extinction because it
never happened it's just it's a
continuous Evolution that's more or less
the way I think they defined it in a
vague way so that they can accommodate
any extinction theories
also and and and it leads to what the
problem is we've never defined what
paleontology is that's where the problem
starts we don't have a definition for
paleontology this is what you'll find
out there okay uh paleontology the
scientific study of ancient life that's
what I would have said well uh first of
all it's not the study of anything we in
science we do not study
okay the word study has to be that's
that's very apparent to some of our
watches we don't study we don't read
books
we don't study yeah anybody can study
and not understand anything so studying
is not science study is what you can do
at home and you can study all you want
but then when you come to the conference
we want a scientific explanation
and the other thing is that
paleontologists don't study life
they study the opposite they study death
if anything they're supposed to explain
how a species became extinct so we don't
study life and you look at the
description there the field seeks
information about several aspects of
past organisms their identity and origin
their environment and evolution what
they can tell us about Earth's organic
and inorganic past that has nothing at
all to do with paleontology okay in
paleontology we have to tell the crowd
how species died and here you see at the
bottom that's also from the Wikipedia it
says uh gives you an idea of what they
think about Extinction or how it happens
is uh when dominance of an ecological
niche passes from one group of organisms
to another this is because they're going
to tell us the why okay the cause and
Extinction event allows a new group to
outlive the old and move into its Niche
that's not an explanation that's a
description so they they put the word
because like saying I'm going to tell
you the cause and they're not giving you
a cause they're saying look it just one
move down the other one moved in and
they're not telling you why what caused
that to happen and so again we don't
have uh explanations for extinction
because the definitions to start out
with are wrong or irrational okay and
this is this is where the problem starts
so what do they think about what is a
paleontologist who who does paleontology
and here you see the
motions that you'll find again a lot of
this from the Wikipedia gives the idea
of what people think a paleontology a
paleontologist is and it's essentially
you know if you've seen the movie
Raiders of the Lost Ark yeah I was gonna
say yeah Indiana Jones that's what the
people think is a paleontologist you
know he goes with a whip with a gun
maybe maybe with a shovel and a pick
like you know oh yeah I forgot my pig
it's like that wasn't important you know
and they have this idea that the guy
just hits the rock pulls a bone out
gives it cleans it out with a brush
gives it a name assembles the bone puts
it in a museum and starts collecting
entrance fees that's not a palliant
that's a stamp collector
so here it is this is the notion people
have okay this is also from the wiki
is from the Wikipedia yeah it shows the
first guy paleontologist at work no
that's not a paleontologist that's a boy
who's cleaning some bones that's not a
paleontologist okay people think that
the guy just goes in there with a pig uh
you know creams some bones and that's a
paleontologist no that's not a
paleontologist paleontologist has to
explain something otherwise he's not
even a scientist and the other guy is
he's preparing some fossilized bones and
then here you have an analysis using
engineering techniques so that T-Rex
right had a devastating bite and and
raised doubts about his running ability
what's that got to do with paleontology
what's that got to do if I who cares if
you ran fast I mean you don't have to
tell me that he had a great bite I can
see that he had a great bite I don't
need to do any study for that because he
built it though I mean
look at those teeth and you run away you
say of course that had a great bite or I
mean do we need to make a study for that
no the the issue is you know these
people think that a paleontologist is an
excavator you know like Fred Flintstone
working in the Quarry uh this is the
idea that people have of what a
paleontologist is and what is Australian
okay so let's find out what Italian
title is just really is okay this is a
paleontologist
how do dinosaurs disappeared okay
science racial explanation paleontology
is a branch of science and what does
explain explain Extinction not just
extinctions also how they lived well
yeah but I mean I'm serious about that
too yeah but how they leave it as a
description it's not like an explanation
I mean if you explain why they live that
way then yeah you kind of have to
backtrack and explain but they don't
explain all they do is they describe and
they say oh this is you know it's like
it's more like theorizing it must have
been like this due to its bone structure
if they do the due to yeah but the
problem is there's not enough Dude too
they don't explain they just say oh this
is what we found we found a bone we
called it this and it roamed in Africa
or wherever that's what it's just
descriptions so he paleontologists is a
forensic pathologist a medical examiner
who determines the cause of death that's
what a that's the primary job at least
of a paleontologist and not what these
people say which is just collecting
bones and giving them names and
assembling them putting them in them
you're saying a paleontologist as a
detective who's really late for the job
late for today is the detective caused
the day after well but it's just a
detective it comes a million years later
but it has to do it has the detectives
always come late for the job yeah but
this is like really late he's like
millions of years late like okay it's
time to solve this crime
okay how did this guy die these are
these are some of the um comments people
made uh regarding Extinction okay first
uh this fellow made this comment first
um last time around okay and so I'm
gonna address what he said because he he
said I didn't address his issue he said
a nation group people can re can start
printing their own new money that will
kick-start the economy
and I want to emphasize kick start the
economy this is what he said what
happens when there is no money we print
them again and start the economy again
and you know emphasize restart Kickstart
and start the economy again no such
monster how hard is it to comprehend
yeah so he says right why didn't you
think of that one so he's saying that
he's saying it's all it's all the
question of printing new money and
that's no big deal because money is just
money I guess right it's no biggie money
you can use Monopoly money if you want
okay I like this game yeah anyways uh
and so uh he says you read only half of
my common and misinterpreted what I
meant I don't say you give free money to
all people
and I put that as an example only as an
example if money is just money it's just
money and you can create uh replace
green money with brown money oh why not
you know give everybody in the world
every person a million dollars I mean if
money is just money what the hell so I'm
not saying that's the solution I'm
saying that this so that you can realize
that it's a nonsense to say that you're
going to um
um just replace green money with brown
money and then and that you can kick
start the the global economy okay
especially the global economy and I'll
get to that in a second are you saying
switching one up for the other well he's
saying this is this is an easy solution
he says to because I'm saying there's
going to be an economic clock the dollar
Falls enough they just make a new one
and start from clean yeah he's saying we
restart the global economy in other
words everybody is poor again starts
with zero right that's a clean
transition right I want to see that is
no longer Rich neither is Trump no one
because we should restart the economy we
clean everybody's bank account you know
and we start all over now we say no more
green money we start with brown money
and why don't we all restart the process
that's more or less so I'm I'm focusing
on the restart the global economy and I
don't think he's got that context in his
brain yet okay this is where the problem
got a few steps to it right yeah just
snap your fingers and we got new money
okay so this is the issue he says
printing nationalized commercial uh
banks credit uh creating credit for
Endeavors such as uh and he names a few
Endeavors there okay says what Hitler
and uh founding fathers money differed
from uh dollars Euros Etc is that they
were printed by government National
Banks therefore interest went back into
budget of a nation and not private
pockets of vultures and they created
great economies well the first thing I
think um the founding fathers would not
like to be put in the same boat as
Hitler that's the first one I think they
had different ideas
so you know you may say well they they
all created new money and so we can do
that again again restarting the economy
and I'm saying this is this is where the
problem is I'm saying that
um first of all Washington you know in
the days of Washington we had an
Agricultural Society we were still in
the agricultural age okay
uh Hitler that was the age of
manufacturing very different age many
things had happened in the in those uh
150 years and today we have the age of
services okay and even worse the last 20
years we've moved into the age of
internet jobs right so now we have the
internet economy you could say uh so
history is no blueprint for today okay
national International Trade has taken
over I'm sorry International Trade has
taken over National trade uh so we're
emphasizing Global over uh local
um
economies right now uh trade
international trade is more important
than uh national uh trade uh in other
words consumption within a country and
again it's a fight between macro and
micro and then like I said in the past
macro trumps micro every time it's the
narcocaps uh
anarcho-capitalists who believe in local
in uh local trade you trade with your
neighbor get government off your back no
taxes the no rules let everybody just
follow his own interests etc etc it's
the old uh Adam Smith uh version you
know everyone pursuing his own
self-interest moves the global economy
forward well that's over you know right
now it's macro that governs the world
and its International Trade that's uh
that's more important than you know
trading with your neighbor
and um so all I'm saying is also uh
finally their new money will not erase
the debt uh ownership of property create
new jobs erase poverty or uh create a
world government which uh in a way these
people are saying because they're saying
remove government and that's like saying
we have no government which was uh also
by the way Marxist thinking you know
originally the idea was that anarchism
uh was the goal and anarchism not in the
bad sense like throwing bombs that kind
of anarchism no what they were saying is
look
the workers take over the means of
production eventually we uh
have a world government and then
government itself ceases to exist that
was the Communist notion the anarchical
capitalists today have reinvented that
in a different way they're trying to get
there not through communism but through
capitalism like saying I'm just going to
do my own trading you know in my
neighbor but the issue is the money is
issued eventually by the government even
the crypto stuff you know all we did was
transfer money from existing you know
from the green bags and Euros Etc into
crypto it's not like we created new
money out there out of nowhere the
government is still fueling that with
just more money that it prints every day
so it's not like we created new money we
have crypto money it's a new kind of
money yeah it is a new kind of money but
it comes from the it's always back from
the government it's not like you're
gonna wipe out all the money in the
world and say okay instead of green
money or blue money now we're gonna have
brown money for everybody
does it come down to the faith of the
new Brown money because if you have if
you for example if all these anarchical
capitals just invented their own money
and they just started trading with that
it would solve all problems except when
someone cheats then who do you call the
cops on for the brown money that the
government doesn't even recognize well
they have a solution for that as well as
saying that there's private courts like
uh you know
um like town halls in the old days where
they could settle things locally without
having you know a global budget aside
from that to enter the other part
is the question
where does that money come from that you
made the trade with your neighbor it
comes from you know the government and
it's it's uh it's not backed people are
aware of that used to be backed by goal
that's long gone now it's now it's uh
you know after uh Breton Woods it's just
uh whatever value you want to give it
and you said uh in your first statement
it's it's all faith it's if if you have
faith in Vietnamese money that you can
do something with it we'll you'll accept
Vietnamese money for your car
not a lot of people will have faith in
Vietnamese money and they will not sell
their car for Vietnamese money and so
the question is money is not money is
not money there's money and there's
Monopoly money you know I mean they're
about the same but more people accept
real money than Monopoly money yeah real
money what is real real money means that
you give it value it could be gold it
could be crypto it could be whatever you
need to give it value yeah but if if we
lose faith if we become atheists in
money
that's it
not much there you know no value
so another fellow says okay he says the
human inter instrumentality project is
about human extinction okay and he says
the project was to have a machine
digital record of humanity so there's
proof we existed after we were gone
proof for whom I mean it's like Carl
Sagan he uh sent this golden record
together uh with a voyager one and also
another one in Voyager two and that was
a kind of like a seti project the search
for extraterrestrial intelligence and
you'll never find it in Harvard or in
Cambridge by the way uh no no
intelligence over there anyways
um they sent these this out there hoping
that someone out there will find it
someday
it's just crazy it'll never happen I
mean it's a nice hope it's hope it's
just it's a nice little gesture but it's
probably on a rock in the middle of
space somewhere no it's that again uh
you know civilizations only last 200 I
mean uh to the point where they can use
electricity
electromagnetism and so on you know uh
it lasts only 200 years
that's not even a drop of water in the
uh Ocean of Time of the Universe I mean
what is 200 years in uh in gazillions of
your in eternity of the universe nothing
and so you have to find not only some
civilization that grew up that evolved
in some Planet within a hundred light
years okay and that's only one way
because round trip for them to answer
that's another 100 light year for them
to send it at the speed of light that's
200 years you're over you're not you
won't receive the message even if they'd
received your message and right now we
haven't found any uh life uh at least at
the level of managing electromagnetism
uh 100 Year 100 light years around us
so on top of the fact someone did find
it they'd just be like oh it's just
another record yeah I mean
one thing you wouldn't even know is
extraterrestrial it would have to
coincide not only in space but in time
space it has to be within at least I
would say 100 uh light years that means
that the speed of light you send a
message and in a hundred years they
receive it that's one issue the other
one has got to be a not only an issue of
distance but it's got to be an issue of
time is that planet I mean when you send
it to them maybe they're still in the
Planet of the Apes over there by the
time you know he gets to them they have
to evolve another the million years
before they become human let me cut all
your things down with some Star Wars
there was a scene in Star Wars where
Luke Skywalker the robot on Luke
Skywalker's ship tells them the check
the odds of him surviving you have 0.2
percent chance of surviving and Luke
Skywalker says never tell me the odds
that's basically don't tell me the odds
just send the record out into space so
in any ways uh even if we leave some
proof that we were here I mean what more
proof than a bunch of skeletons on the
last day of Earth you come here you see
I mean if the Martians come here yeah
they did yeah someone lived here you
know I mean but what are the chances of
someone coming here none absolutely none
it's uh less than zero okay
okay another fella says uh we need
something like a land reform because uh
well uh
because most of the land is monopolized
by corporations uh maybe at some point
for survival reasons it will have to
come down to stealing Farmland from them
and all I can do is uh remind you that
we had the what is known as the
enclosure movement uh probably started
around the 12th century but it really
took quite a bit of effect in these uh
15 and 16 centuries which is uh when
they started enclosing the land and
kicking the poor people out because what
we're up to that point public lands were
being enclosed and when they were
enclosed they drove the people who used
to take their cattle or whatever the
horse there they eat and suddenly that
land was not available to them a lot of
these people had to go to the cities
find jobs in there and the land became
more productive by the people who were
profiting from them in other words uh
they made it more productive and uh this
comes from the enclosure movement you
can look that up in Wikipedia the
appropriation of common land and closing
it and by doing so depriving commoners
you know like you and me and the rights
of access and privilege the primary
reason for enclosure was to improve the
efficiency of Agriculture and it was
really not in the 15th and 16th century
it was not so much agriculture it was
sheep they were she was very lucrative
for a lot of these landowners and so
they said I'm gonna put sheep in there
and you get your horses your cows
whatever you've got out of here and so
they would kick all the poor people out
and Thomas Moore wrote in Utopia his uh
15 16 book
your sheep which are naturally mild and
easily kept in order may be said now to
devour men and unpeople on people so on
people like you and me I like them and
we're gonna be eaten by sheep not today
I mean maybe not by sheep but uh
whatever the agricultural uh
corporations decide to grow or you know
the UN people
uh whatever they decide to do with the
land I mean they're the owners of the
land and supposedly they're running it
more efficiently than if we have all
these little Farmers doing their own
thing so yeah farmers are being bought
out a lot of them are being driven into
bankruptcy they can't pay some of the
bank loans so they have to sell their
land and even though they're they had
generations of you know their
forefathers lived in that land now
they've got to move out big corporations
are taking over those lands they have
money they have some tax breaks from the
government
uh et cetera Etc and what they're doing
supposedly they're plowing you know the
land much better than a small farmer who
cannot compete against them in on the
market and little by little we're
getting rid of a small farmer that's why
we advance Nations like you know Germany
or the United States uh maybe one
percent to two percent of their
population and of their GDP is
agriculture that's how efficient we are
the rest is all manufacturing and
services we can't rely on a little
farmer anymore so the big corporations
are buying the land making it more
efficient are we ever going to get it
back I don't think so we're going to
stay in the cities looking for jobs or
relying on government help that's more
or less the situation right now that's
why I don't think that is sustainable
for the next million years absolutely
not that's why I'm saying we are the
last generation of humans on Earth
here's another comment says you claim
that you caught arthritis this is
related now to a lot of people have
these ideas about medicines and the rich
and Powerful who are poisoning us with
their food Etc right they are okay
diseases are consequences of bad
lifestyle and wrong diet where obviously
raw vegan primates as no sane animal
Cooks its food okay raw vegan diet
natural hygienists have rational
explanations for disease formation they
did it uh in 19th century Rockefeller
took over medicine and transformed it
into snake oil salesmanship in 1910 uh
live longer stay away from quacks in
white coats okay so what can I say to
this fella he uh obviously has a grudge
against some of these um
rich people who he believes are
poisoning us maybe with additives and so
on so here's my first comment on that
okay these people the Filthy Rich do
they eat foods with additives or do they
avoid them and just give them to us on
people
I love that word we're young people so
are these people poisoning us only or do
they eat hamburgers as well no no they
have uh real people food yeah
you think they eat differently than we
do or definitely eat differently but I
mean how differently because I mean do
they ever eat a hamburger do they ever
put sugar in their coffee that's the
thing I mean no matter what that food
rolls around all over the place and how
are they supposed to track who gets the
poison food there you go so I don't
think that's the case but uh I'm more
concerned about this fell with uh
talking about vegans
um vegan you know I I eat veggies in
fact I was thinking the other day
that uh I like almost all vegetables
there's almost I don't think there's a
vegetable I don't like anymore I used to
not like beets when I was a kid my
mother used to do bors she did it very
well but uh I didn't like boars I didn't
I liked the board but I didn't like the
beets and I didn't like sauerkraut which
is again you know she prepared it very
well but I didn't like it and today I
even eat those so I don't think there's
a single veggie I don't like anymore
but uh I mean I mean I love to eat the
salami with wine I don't think those
those two are good for your health but I
just love it and I I'd rather live one
year less and continue eating that stuff
and not uh not avoid them but the issue
is you know some people have problems
with the
um ethical part uh the fact that we're
killing animals in fact we're doing even
worse we're uh putting them in Corrals
we're putting them in pig pens we're
putting chickens in little cages and
people say well that's immoral it's
unethical
um what can I say you know we are the
top predator of the
uh of the of the world and we can do
anything we want we're like gods and
people don't like that says we have too
much power we shouldn't be abusing the
poor little animals and we shouldn't be
killing cows we shouldn't be killing
pigs and so on they think it's
disgusting it's a disgusting practice
and all I can say we've done it for
thousands of years I mean you know those
Spears that our ancestors had they were
not to hunt lettuce or tomatoes or catch
apples from the tree no they were to
kill animals and we were primarily
Hunters we killed animals and thanks to
our forefathers we are here okay now the
new generations they have their tummies
filled and now they have opinions and
they say well maybe we shouldn't be
killing animals anymore you know they
have their opinions this is a
condescending way to put it they all you
have your little opinion and
and here we have the famous Pita people
and what do they say well uh this is
this is their take on uh on ethics okay
any uh known as the people for ethical
treatment of animals otherwise known as
Peta and they oppose what species
speciesism okay what is that non-human
abnormals are not objects that belong to
us they're individuals with their own
interests just like us addressing uh
speciesism and acknowledging other
animals rights can be as simple as
respecting their needs or leaving them
in peace
you know I can't imagine a lion thinking
like this you know Lions don't uh have
ethics
in fact I was uh watching one day uh how
a
um was it a um
leopard had caught a baby gazelle
and he didn't kill it because he
realized that baby gazelle couldn't run
away from him and she was playing with
like cat and mouse you know playing with
the gazelle the gazelle tried to run a
little bit and he and the Jaguar would
catch him back again and Far Away was uh
the gazelle's mother looking at the
whole scene and trying and seeing you
know just suffering for her baby there
well the Jaguar eventually took the baby
up a tree and ate them
now uh no ethics here no no uh no pity
and I think what we have to understand
is Mother Nature does not care one Yoda
about love
there is no love out there in fact she
wants the opposite she wants competition
killing uh you're supposed to hunt the
day that we become complacent and we
introduce love or ethics into the
picture we are violating mothers
Nature's law
okay so we don't want love because
Mother Nature doesn't understand love
and here it is [ __ ] up when you put it
like that but it makes sense here's
here's mother nature and this is what
she says she said I invented love 74
reproduction hmm that's what love is
according to Mother Nature that's
physics
okay that we have in our minds you know
humans have distorted my intentions and
used love for pleasure and Recreation
you know the fact that we get a kick out
of it out of
um
I love uh you know uh we take it a
little further and we say oh ethics and
so on you know Mother Nature doesn't
care she wants War she wants killing she
wants Murder She wants the lion to kill
the wildebeest because that's what she
made the lion for and to say well the
lion now has to give up his practice and
be kind to the wildebeest and so on you
know and uh here's another vision of
what love is to Mother Nature and what
it is to others okay that do not follow
her rules okay so
um here we have
here we have you know a situation where
you know we think that love has to do
with attraction of some kind now she
doesn't care about that she wants
reproduction that's the only purpose of
love as far as Mother Nature is
concerned that's pure physics anything
outside of that any consideration for
some other animal for she doesn't care
about that okay and let me let me put it
in a different way you know because
people are for sure going to string me
even my my staunches uh supporter would
want to kill me here and I say that
there are animals that we should kill
deliberately we should kill us no no
well but we should kill the lion all
lions on Earth we have the power to do
we should do that we should kill all
lions all alligators all wolves all
animals which are dangerous we have no
need for these animals other than Beauty
uh whatever you want to call it okay
what's wrong with that
yeah some beauty Mother Nature doesn't
like Beauty she didn't invent these
animals she said you have to if you're
the top predator you're supposed to kill
everyone yeah T-Rex did not have any
compassion for anyone below it oh yeah
what I would say to that is we've
essentially killed them off and now
we're just keeping around keeping him
around his toys now we have them for
zoos for entertainment that's not what
their what Mother Nature Made the lion
for she made the lion so that we would
kill them all that's why she made the
LIE okay he's a competitor the lion is a
competitor of ours we're supposed to
kill him because he's a dangerous animal
for us so does the alligator so is the
shark I mean
we have no need for them if you think to
the extreme according to Mother Nature
we should be doing whatever we are doing
right if we're doing it then that's what
we see programmed us to do it we kill
other humans forget about the animals we
killed other humans that's what mother
of nature wants he wants competition she
wants killing murder
got a lot of bloodthirsty kill them all
okay folks let's go on to the muon what
is yeah after killing everyone
okay here's the new one you always
wanted to see what immune looks like
here it is folks okay take a look good
look take a snapshot if you want there
it is uh how long do you spend on that
picture of us well not supposed to be I
guess that's not the muon that I had in
mind no I I think this is the muon okay
it looks something like that one
it's that little uh M there at the
bottom okay uh the letter mu that's
what's called a muon and as you can see
it doesn't look like a particle looks
like a Trace
so the mutant is a trace I mean what is
this thing uh called the muon yeah what
is a muing you know what I mean I
thought mutin was supposed to be a
particle so well let's find out I looked
it up and find out what is a viewing I
mean that's I heard that it's something
well it's it's not the cow that says mu
on it's not the little tray so what is a
muon and you look it up man okay and
here it is the definition of what a muon
is okay it says uh you know on an
elementary particle okay
similar to the electron with another
charge of blah blah blah any spin of
half but with a much greater mass so all
it is is a heavy electron okay
it is classified as a lepton okay as
with other leptons the muon is not
thought to be composed of any simpler
particles that is it is a fundamental
part is that fundamentophorical okay so
they they break it apart and then you
find yeah this is crazy because they say
it's an elementary particle a
fundamental particle in both cases it
means that it's not made of anything
simpler it doesn't have components and
then they talk about breaking it up and
creating neutrons neutrinos with it you
know and electrons and it says muon is
an unstable subatomic particle with a
life mean lifetime of 2.2
um
um what is it
um microseconds okay so uh it lasts very
little 2.2 Microsoft just long enough
for them to get their calculation out
more or less you don't need it anymore
but this is the issue the issue is they
say it's a particle
okay so now we know what it is some kind
of particle it's going to be on the
standard model but then you look up and
you find this uh this in there this
phone and his name is David Tong he's a
physicist or mathematical physicist
right and he says something different he
says and we talked about this uh in the
past uh recent past so it's kind of
brushing up when we talked about a
little while ago it says the best
theories we have is that the fundamental
building blocks of nature are not
particles
are not particles I thought the immune
was a particle now it is saying
fundamental the fundament well this is a
fundamental particle right so you're
saying they're not particles so okay so
what are they but something much more
nebulous and Abstract the fundamental
building blocks of nature are fluid like
substances
light substances I guess molasses which
are spread throughout the entire
universe
so so we have this uh particle that is
not really a particle it's some kind of
nebulous abstract substance which is
spread throughout the entire universe
and ripple in strange in interesting
ways these fluid-like substances we have
a name for we call them fields
so you're saying this uh this muon is is
not really a particle because we're
talking about elementary particles
you're saying well Elementary particles
fundamental particles are not really
particles you know like a corpuscle you
know it's like a little dot there no
it's uh some kind of thing that
substance that is spread out throughout
the whole universe
so it's kind of weird because it's very
hard to imagine a little particle that
is also at the same time spread out
throughout the Universe what are these
talking about it's a really big particle
yeah the biggest particle you ever saw
or in a big particle and here here you
see uh he continues he says if you're a
physicist you have very different
picture in your mind when you think
about fields and I'll tell you the
general definition of a field okay what
is it it's something okay something
right that is spread everywhere
throughout the Universe okay so they
like the field why because it's spread
out and they're going to explain or try
to explain with this word field uh
action at a distance that's what they
cannot explain they cannot explain pull
specifically they'll force a pull and so
the field comes in handy uh when the
particle fails they cannot with a
discrete particle explain pull or action
at a distance that's the issue and he
says it's something that takes a
particular value at every point in space
so we have values at each point in space
which doesn't concern us that's a
mathematical description it has nothing
to do with what a field is if it's a if
it if it's a what at all okay and we're
talking about what's what is a what a
what is an object a thing and we're not
talking about things so far they're
talking about values what's more that
value can change in time again to tell
you about math here not not physics so a
good picture to have in your mind is a
fluid which Ripples and sways throughout
the Universe and there you have a
picture of what they think is vacuum
they say the vacuum when they remove
everything from the vacuum you still
have whatever that nonsense is there
they say those are fields
whatever field is because again I see
only discrete things in there and
they're saying that the field is like
something which is continues all the way
to the edge of space-time that's not
what they're illustrating there but they
illustrate these looks like particles
appearing from the void and they're
saying these are Fields okay so so we
have a problem because what they
illustrate does not match what they're
saying in fact I doubt very much anyone
can illustrate a field because there are
different Notions of what a field is and
it's all ad hoc when they need the field
for this they'll put all these little
particles and they say they pop in from
the void and they vibrate and when you
say well how does it affect that thing
over there well it's continuous yeah it
stretches all the way to there like an
ocean where else do you need it over
there stretches there too and again the
notion that they're giving you is that
you have this ocean and you have the
waves okay and the waves are the local
vibrations of the ocean
so the local vibrations the particle and
the ocean is the field one problem with
that is that that's a two-dimensional
picture notion or visualization because
you're talking about what's happening on
the surface that's a wave
and our universe is at least 3D as far
as the eye can see and so you would
think that you know how do you wave
something within
the ocean
what is it a current what is this you
know so that's true
uh it's a surrealistic vision that these
people have you know okay anyways here's
the formal definition of field okay uh
shown this in the past and not going to
go through all this again but it's a
quantity okay it's a number that has a
value for each point in space and time
okay so he's right it's a mathematical
concept this thing called field so we
start off on on the wrong foot because
uh we're supposed to find out what a
field is like a what a thing and it's
not a thing it's a mathematical concept
an abstract mathematical concept and
that's what underlies the muon which is
supposed to be an elementary particle
which is a field
so you can see where this is going we
start out on the wrong foot okay because
the muon turns out to be some kind of
vibrating field which is a bunch of
vibrating values
okay so far so good catching up okay
schedule the definitions yeah
yeah what they did is avoid the
definition in fact you're you're not
supposed to Define if if a muon is a
thing
you're supposed to point to it like you
point to a table and say that's a thing
what do you call it I call this this
thing a table and that one a stone and
that one a tree then we can all
understand so you have to point and say
muon that's not what they do they say
look it's a field and what is a field
will it's a bunch of numbers and they
vibrate and it stretch all the way to
the edge of space time you know that's
that's an explanation we don't need a
definition we need for them to point to
the muon okay so here this fellow again
continues and he says you take these two
magnets and you move them together as
they get closer and closer there's this
force that you can feel uh building up
that the pressure that pushes against
these two magnets it's just a little bit
magical this was Faraday Faraday's
genius it was to appreciate that even
though you can't see anything in between
the space between these magnets will
seem to be empty he said nonetheless
what there's something real and physical
there
okay so a field is something in there
not the field itself but something in
there inside the field is physical and
real which is invisible responsible for
the force he called the lines of force
in other words a field is made of lines
of force it's not the field which is the
object it's the line of force which he's
saying is the object We Now call it the
magnetic field meaning all the lines of
force yeah
what we need to identify is the line of
force what is this line of force not the
field field is a bunch of the lines of
force what he envisaged was that what
threaded everywhere throughout space
where these invisible objects I heard
that one before sounds like the Rope
model there you know it's shredded
everywhere throughout space were these
invisible objects that comes out of a
so-called mathematical physicist yeah
you have to have objects in there you
have to have things that are threaded
throughout the Universe and connect
things that's what the notion that they
want to give you with field okay but
then when you're asking well what really
is a field it's a bunch of numbers
well that's not what you just said you
said that everything is threaded
throughout and it's the threaded
throughout being objects right of course
that's what uh uh what what a field is
the the all the all the things that
comprise the field which are the
threaded throughout okay and so yeah you
need physical objects to do physics and
for that you absolutely need you know to
uh
illustrate the object that you're
referring to okay and yeah Faraday and
Maxwell both set it here it is uh
Faraday said I cannot concede curved
lines of force without conditions of a
physical existence in that intermediate
space and Maxwell said more or less the
same thing he defined it in uh his book
uh field the space in the neighborhood
of the electric and magnetic bodies in
that space there is what matter in
motion matter in motion that's what a
field is the field is not a thing it's a
concept it's a dynamic concept made of
matter which is in motion
what you have to identify is what is
that matter what does it look like uh
what do we have there what is that
invisible region there that has this uh
you know object that's moving around
inside the field that's what you got to
identify until you do that you're not
doing physics you're doing math Maybe
okay so here's uh the muon and follow
synthesizes he says cosmic rays made up
mostly of protons collide with molecules
of Earth's atmosphere creating muons
that's the origin that's the birth of
the muon okay there's a collision
between uh cosmic rays which are
primarily protons they Collide against
something okay could be the atmosphere
of Earth and now they're going to create
this thing called muon which allegedly
is an elementary or fundamental particle
which is a field which is who knows what
okay stationary muons have a mean
lifetime of 2.2 microseconds stationary
muon uh could take about 34 microseconds
to fall distance 10 kilometers from
Earth's surface if they're traveling
close to the speed of light okay so you
know you would have 34 microseconds
again uh maybe 17 times as much as the
stationary muon okay so this one's
traveling it reaches the Earth if it can
live
uh 34 microseconds but they say well the
average lifetime of a mu has 2.2 so
there's no way it would arrive at the
Earth surface
yet many muons reach the ground they do
reach no ground that means that they
apparently are living more than 2.2
microseconds they have to live at least
34 microseconds if they want to reach
the ground so how is this possible there
seems to be a contradiction there time
dilation you know muon lifetime larger
for an observer on Earth that's what's
happening what's happening is they bring
time dilation special relativity to
explain why the muon survives all the
way to the Earth despite the fact that
it only lives 2.2 microseconds
instead of the 34 that it would need to
reach what does the Observer on earth
have to do with them either the muon
lived two second to win two microseconds
or it hit the ground well here it is
yeah they're mutually exclusive no
matter what you do you would think and
that's what I'm going to show right now
but let's get to this point uh rather
than uh question the the idiocy of
quantum mechanics the mathematician used
the muon as proof of special relativity
okay so they're instead of saying look
there's something wrong we need to erase
the board and start all over they said
oh we have a solution
the solution is that if we bring special
relativity in we can explain why the
muon reaches all the way to the Earth
despite the fact that it would uh be
required that it lives 17 times more
than it usually lives this is the
problem we have a problem there and they
solved it with special rocks length and
time for itself just to hit the ground
yeah okay so here's the description out
of the Wikipedia although their lifetime
without relativistic effects would allow
a half survival distance of only 456
meters the time dilation effect of
special relativity uh from the Viewpoint
of the earth meaning The Observer right
allows cosmic ray secondary muons to
survive the flight all the way to the
Earth's surface since in the earth frame
the muons have a longer Half-Life due to
their velocity from the Viewpoint of the
muon now we have the muon and he's going
to be thinking he's going to be
analyzing himself okay muon on the other
hand it is the length contraction effect
of special relativity which allows this
penetration since the muon frame its
lifetime is unaffected but like it says
there length contraction causes
distances through the atmosphere and
Earth to be far shorter better than
these distances in the earth's rest
frame so we see it as
thousands of kilometers and it sees it
as only 400 meters exactly the muon has
a short I know we see it is traveling
and the mean one says no it's only 300
meters what'd you tell you about yeah
the distance for it is shortened but not
for us and that comes out of Einstein's
relativity which says that when you're
traveling at the speed of light you know
what you see in your frame of reference
is different than what the Observer from
far away sees for you everything is
normal you know you look around yourself
everything is on everything stationary
more or less you know the tear is there
and everything but if the Earth is
flying at the speed of light right the
person uh far away will see you a little
different or it will time you a little
different than what your timing things
happening around you that's more or less
the idea behind the muon and uh so so
here we have one MIT
mathematical physicist and then he gives
us an example he says you know lifetime
again two microseconds right if the
particle were moving at nearly the speed
of light it could only move about 600
meters how can a particle that is
produced 20 kilometers above the Earth
reach the ground if it decays into
microseconds special relativity Saves
the Day suppose the muon is moving at
99.99 of the speed of light as seen on
the surface of the Earth time dilation
stretches out its lifetime to makes the
calculation comes out to 140
microseconds with this lifetime the muen
can travel a distance of 42 kilometers
before decaying the muiron can easily
make it from high up in the atmosphere
to the ground okay this was published by
the MIT people okay okay
um
so there you have the example uh muon is
essentially a particle of distance
tribal as I say and for this we need to
distinguish between distance and
distance traveled those two have nothing
one has nothing to do with the other
okay they're they're comparing apples
and oranges the mathematicians as always
okay so here you have a muon okay it's
going to go in a straight line all the
way to the Earth okay
so uh they say this is the new one
shouldn't be doing that because it only
lasts 2.2 microseconds and it would take
at least 17 times as much if it travels
close to the speed of light to reach the
Earth okay so so what happens
uh what we're looking at is the
locations okay what you're what you just
stared at uh was a movie a film of the
muon falling and if we chop that up into
all the frames right uh each location
that it has with respect to the Earth
right then you would have something like
this you would have different locations
of the muons okay you would just
partition it into frames or locations in
this case frames and location frames of
the movie and locations you could say uh
are the same thing okay so what is the
issue here okay why don't we have the MU
on so that we can distinguish between
distance and distance travel let's have
the muon travel only halfway okay so
here goes
Newman only travels halfway now we're
going to look at that situation there
okay
and here we have it
there it is you have the uh on the one
hand you have all the frames in the film
of the distance that it traveled and on
the other you're going to have the
distance that it still has not uh
traveled okay so one is a movie and the
other one is a like a photograph it's a
static image of a separation okay from
the um
ended up last to the Earth's surface and
here you have uh we we label this so
that you know what we're talking about
here when is distance traveled and the
other one is distance distance just
separation whereas distance traveled is
again uh all the locations that the uh
muon had on its trip to halfway beaten
from its starting point to the surface
of the Earth okay
and we label that one more time just to
make sure one is a movie and the other
one is a picture okay so that we
understand exactly what hopefully
everybody understands what we're talking
about here we're saying that one is
distance traveled the other one is
distance separation okay one is a movie
and the other one is a picture even
photographs photograph because it's more
like a mental well it's aesthetic it's
aesthetic what I'm saying is distance is
a static concept where this and traveled
is not yeah distance traveled is motion
distance is uh you know just a
separation yeah okay that's what I'm
trying to say here okay so we got that
at least the Notions what's the problem
well first thing we have to do is define
words so that we know what we're talking
about let's define them okay we say that
an object is that which has shape
distance is the separation between
objects okay we have two objects there
two blue boxes and this is just a
region between them that has no matter
uh location is the set of distances one
object with respect to all the other
objects in the universe and distance
traveled something totally different we
call it motion displacement you can call
it if you want two or more locations of
an object that's a dynamic concept okay
so these are all different uh Notions
different concepts and so we need to
understand the differences between them
okay so what's the issue
when uh when the forefathers people like
Lawrence and uh Juan Carrey and so on
they came up with this uh length
contraction as they call it uh they were
actually comparing apples and Origins
just because length is not distance okay
length has to be it has to do with what
an object measures and not with the
separation between two objects which is
what distance is so we got length
distance and then distance and this
would travel something totally different
because it's a it's what what one object
travel it has nothing to do with
separation say distance is the length of
space it's a weird way to put it but
yeah but length should be reserved for
objects for things that's where the
problem is okay so they use this but
look at this the issue is that that
velocity there is uh distant traveled
and not distance and today everybody
uses the word distance when it's not
distance it's very confusing because
people think that they're talking about
separation and they're not they're
talking about a movie they're talking
about a little ball that is at different
locations that's what velocity has to do
with and not with separation between two
objects okay so that's the first thing I
want to point out
okay and here we have
um
uh my versions to show you the
difference distance is what lies between
lengths yeah that's a way we like to
synthesize that length is what an object
has the table has length uh between two
tables what we have is distance okay
now that essentially is like what I said
distance is distance is the length an
object would have if it were in between
those two yeah but see the issue here is
that the
petitions whether they're going to
measure a table or whether they're going
to measure between two tables they have
to unroll the measuring tape and what
they're doing in all these cases is
measuring uh or counting how many units
of that measuring tape either the table
has or between two tables in other words
for them it's all the same they're going
to talk about meters and what they're
doing is counting the number of meters
between two tables or one inch of the
table to the other edge of the table or
the amount of time you ran all that for
them is the same it doesn't matter so
it's like the the issue with dimensions
and coordinates and vectors for them
it's all the same because they're not
talking about Dimensions uh coordinates
or vectors what they're talking about is
number lines and here they commit the
same crime but how is that irrelevant
okay let's show why it's relevant here
it is
okay
here we have location location this is
what I want you to pay attention to here
we have the universal movie okay
Universal movie every frame is a
location now you can chop that up as as
much as you want you can say that every
frame just represents one gazillions of
a gazillionth of a second it doesn't
matter really you can also say that's
just one second the important thing here
is that you see the Green Dot there
that's moving around it has location
with respect to every atom in the
universe okay that's what the red arrows
are Point are showing so but there has
to be a correlation between the
universal movie every matter in the
universe and the local movement of the
muon okay the locom movement of the muon
is a movie also and there has to be
correlation because the local movie of
the muon is a a
um a component of the universal movie so
there better be a one-to-one relation
this is not the case in mathematical
physics what you're saying is time moves
everything at the same time yeah if not
a little faster for this guy and a
little slower for that guy
this guy everyone's speed has to be this
time this is the way I put it what we
look at here is the following
what we have is the phone uh you have
God you know God is all-powerful if you
don't like God you pray to the devil
okay let's put the devil in there okay
the devil uh stops the universe there's
nothing moving
no electron is moving no atom is moving
nothing is moving he froze the entire
universe all the matter in the universe
that's a cross-section of time okay so
that cross-section of time is
cross-section of motion location that's
all we have in that frame of the movie
all we have is location
the next one the next frame is also
location just location so we have motion
built from all these locations because
motion is two or more locations of an
object okay okay there has to be a
correlation locally to the rest of the
universe yeah okay so if if a muon is
moving here in this region uh originally
right we don't care because the location
of that muon at any point in time has to
correlate to the rest of the universe so
it's got to have a distance to every
object in the universe yeah that's my
point okay and so here we see let's put
it back
here we see that according to
mathematics that those 10 frames that
you see there they only form a small
portion less than one second of the
universal movie The Universal movie is
is every object and the distance from
every atom in the universe to every
other atom in the universe that includes
every muon in the universe yeah okay and
what these people are saying is the muon
uh lived or thinks it traveled only less
than one second meaning it got rid of a
lot of frames or it's missing some of
the frames of the universal movie
somehow these people made the movie The
you know some of the frames in the movie
some of the locations disappear yeah
because there's no other way that you
can say that for the muon it was less
than a second but for the universal
movie the whole thing lasted more than
one second so you're saying father time
has to audit the muon well buddy you're
missing some frames here what I'm saying
essentially is you know you can't have
it both ways yeah math is one thing they
can do all the calculations they want
they can take Lawrence uh contraction
and do whatever they want play around
with the numbers but that's fine they
can do whatever they want there but when
they come to the to physics
the muon has to have location
okay that's a qualitative notion it has
to have distance with respect to every
atom in the universe and if you say look
locally what happened to the muon it uh
it did this very fast below one second
at the same time that for the rest of
the universe it was more than one second
okay let's just put in those terms yeah
you can't have that because location has
to be for every frame of the movie and
these people are saying look we got rid
of some of the frames some of the
locations but only in one of the movies
locally yeah
so one of the two someone's missing or
someone's uh
too many frames of the movie depending
on what side you're looking at from with
the context uh there has to be a
location per frame one location per
frame for every you have to account for
every location the muon in every frame
of the move essentially that's how
they're doing one second passes
the same for everything
the I mean the best way to put it like
is kind of how you define a year
the Sun the earth going around the Sun
once
assuming we we made this really slow
right how many times did the let's let's
say a muon lasts one year for itself in
two years for everyone else right did
the earth go once or twice around the
Sun yeah by the time you hit the the
Earth and all we have to do is go to the
file cabinet the devil's file cabinet
opened it up and find out what was the
location on that file and we pulled it
up and that's a single frame of the
movie it has only location the muon had
better be in there okay in every frame I
should see them and these people are
saying no we got rid of some of them
only locally for the muon but the rest
of the movie the rest of the movie
Universal movie is okay but isn't that a
general problem with uh special
relativity
yeah and it's just a general problem
because that is essentially what they're
saying they're saying for some things
time goes faster for some things it goes
slower yeah that's okay in math you can
do all the calculations you want but
we're talking about qualitative location
how many frames every object in the
universe had better have locations
if if two if Point what
two microseconds or was it yeah two
microseconds two microseconds passed
right is the muon dead or did it hit the
ground
we don't care about about the rest of it
where is the meal right now after two
microseconds
look at look at the files no but
essentially that's what you're saying
from this beginning of when the muon
started just start the timer two
microseconds is it dead or did it hit
the ground there might there there uh uh
mutually exclusive it's either dead
so it so only two microseconds passed or
hit the ground so the muon loses more
than two microseconds well what they
they they try to get around that saying
that what the muon experience yeah yeah
yeah it's different than what you
experienced as the Observer and I'm
saying you don't care why people observe
what they calculate we don't care about
it has to be one location per frame in
the Universal movement and the mule had
better be in each one of those frames
and you cannot say well for the muon
there were 10 frames but for the
universe where there were a million
frames you can't do that I mean this is
what they're saying they're they're
eliminating locations of the mule so I'm
saying we got an audit The View on hey
buddy you're missing some frames oh we
got to go to the devil's cabin and find
out what's in there someone's cooking
the books over here
anyways here's the uh conclusions okay
oh sorry wrong one let me get rid of
this one
how many frames per second does the
universe play in well you can you can
make it micro gazillions of a second I
don't care it doesn't matter to me
really chop it up as much as you want
but there had better be the location for
every object in the unit otherwise the
muon disappeared or some of the frames
disappear okay so here's the conclusion
yuan is uh supposedly a particle but a
particle is a field and a field is many
values let's put the sad smile well
you'll see it why uh
uh so this implies that the muon is a
concept it's not an object it's not a
thing okay muon is a concept because
it's just the many values which is a
mathematical concept
muon even worse it's a dynamic concept
why because it's the particle quotations
on that of distance traveled muon only
has importance in the discussion of
distance travel okay because they want
to show you that you know the muon went
faster than what you're supposed to
uh think about the muon you know and the
way they explain through special
relativity saying well for the muon it
was a shorter distance
okay can we really quick talk about why
they even invented the muon well let me
finish this and we'll do that uh they
they depicted as a trace okay and the
mirror is again distance traveled should
have it should have one to one uh
correspondence or relation uh between uh
frames of the movie of The Universal
movie which reproduce each one each
frame represents a location only which
is the set of distances to every atom in
the universe every living thing or every
piece of matter in the universe okay
anything that exists uh that's for the
universal movie and uh what they're
doing is they're either missing or they
have Surplus frames depending on the
context what you're from which angle
you're looking at yeah muon's missing or
we're adding too many right and uh so
the muon has nothing to do with science
and that's why he's got a smiley face
I'm sorry yeah the smell is no longer
smiling why because the muon is not part
of science
okay so the issue is the following the
way they detect this that's what you got
to look at
again
um you have cosmic rays which are
protons they Cola essentially uh they
Collide against the atmosphere or
whatever doesn't matter and when they
Collide they break up okay and the muon
uh travels to Earth okay travels to
Earth but if it's a stationary muon one
that's just floating out there it should
the average lifespan is 2.2 microseconds
when they're traveling to Earth they
should be
um it should take them uh a little more
than 2.2 microseconds okay whatever the
calculation is not important but the
point is it's got to have a longer
lifetime yeah and what they realize is
that
somehow they detect them at ground level
they were able to detect Nuance at
ground level they say how can this
possibly bleed the Miron should have
died by now it turns out he didn't die
he went all the way down there and
instead of rejecting the whole nonsense
of muons what they said is
let's explain it with special relativity
and special relativity says oh length
contraction distance contraction you
know the two mountains move closer to
each other because the muon travels
between them uh you know this is not
nonsense yeah yeah that's what they're
saying and I'm saying hey no problem
with all that that's math now when you
come to physics show me locations of the
music right or I want to see the new on
that every uh location in every frame of
the universal move
okay let's get on to our science critic
we we always
no he's criticizing the scientific
method can you believe the 400 years
later or something like that yeah
anyways here he is he is going to talk
about experiments he's saying
experiments are part of you know science
and what we're saying uh no they're not
and so listen to him here he goes listen
carefully
foreign
s to be addressed in this rebuttal
include are experiments a part of
science
and thus performing an experiment make
you a scientist
Bill what do you think scientists do
with their time after they graduate do
you think that they just sit around
reading books or something I mean sure
reading will definitely be a part of it
there is peer review that has to be done
after all but you know you actually have
to write papers when you're a scientist
and most likely you'll also have to do
experiments in order to verify the
things that you're talking about
studying can be done by performing
experiments which is something that
scientists do when studying I remember
that a large part of my studies were
Hands-On especially when it came to
things like audio production where you
had to set up mics because how else are
you going to learn I have studied
computers and audio that does not make
me a scientist
okay so he says that experiments are
part of science but at the same time he
says doing experiments and studying does
not make you a scientist he seems to
have a contradiction I don't think he
understands what he even said because on
the one hand he says studying and
experiments are part of science or
defines science and then on the other
side well the fact that you study and
that you do experiments do not make you
a scientist okay so here we go uh the
this is a summary essentially of my
criticism of his criticism okay here it
goes
uh science is not studying okay because
you can study all day all night all year
you can study at the University level
and not understand a thing or be able to
explain anything and what is science
science is rational explanations
otherwise you're not a scientist if you
haven't explained anything well it
depends on how you define study well if
you're study and you can't explain
someone some would argue you didn't
study at all well you could study it
doesn't mean you you're going to
understand you can read a book on math
and not understand anything maybe you
don't have the foundations to understand
what you're reading or whatever it
doesn't matter the point is that if you
cannot explain
you're not a scientist because science
is explanation are you saying wait let
me break that down a little more are you
saying that taking in information isn't
the scientific part
that's like that's right right that's
more or less spitting out information as
a scientific partly as much as you take
you could read every book in the world
you're not a scientist yet even even if
you know everything until you spit it
out of your mouth you're not a scientist
and it's not only special yeah hold it
but yeah but it's not just spitting out
in the sense that oh I just say uh
whatever I wrote I I recite poetry no no
that's not science science is explain to
me something but you could be reciting
an explanation that someone else as long
as it's an explanation no problem
but you would definitely cut off between
if the guy read the every single
Wikipedia and he could explain
everything he's not a scientist yet
until he explains I'm saying he's got to
explain because if he just um even if he
recites I mean I don't care you know
because maybe it's his theory he he
needs to read it I don't care but it's
got to be an explanation if it's just a
description
what did he do with it his brain I mean
I can describe a chair that doesn't make
me a scientist it's kind of weird when
you put it like that then you could you
could make that identity thing you could
extrapolate that to anything a
businessman you're not a businessman if
you read every Business book in the
world until you actually do business or
in your business or explain something in
business that's the thing unless you do
something with it you're not you're not
a doer you're just a consumer yeah and
in uh science yeah it means you have to
explain it at the conference when you
come to the conference we don't want you
to describe something or say this is
what I did in my basement so what so
what that you did this in your which is
what paraday used to do he would do all
these experiments at the uh Royal
Society where he did things with
magnetism and electricity he didn't
understand anything but he says look
look how neat this is so so he just
wowed them with his flashy experiments
but he couldn't explain any of them but
I mean so does that make Faraday a
scientist I mean who cares if they're a
scientist or not really all we care
about is the explanation and we don't
care about the person anyways here it is
uh study does not imply you can explain
right the purpose of experiments is to
collect evidence what is the purpose of
evidence to persuade persuade uh
convince convert recruit all that has to
do with religion okay that's opinion
that goes unbelief you know the tax
belief it doesn't explain anything it's
just trying to convince you you know by
my by my theory please that's that's
what it's all about that's what uh
experiments are about well some would
argue that you you need to do
experiments to even get the questions
yeah but that's that's research research
is not science yeah but that's kind of
part of it because you're not trying to
explain uh things of other dimensions
that we can't even I can do all the
research I want that doesn't mean I can
explain it yeah yeah yeah but it is kind
of part you can't rip out the I do the
EXP until you drop the pencil there's no
gravity to explain for for this for this
you need to Define what science is and
if science is explanation it rules out
any investigation it rules out any
research any exp anything that you did
in your dark basement we don't care when
you come to the conference please
explain otherwise you know what are you
gonna do just say this is the experiment
I did at home okay it's like Faraday
used to do oh yeah you said okay what
did you understand I didn't understand
anything
why does it have to be either or why
does it have to be either experiment or
only or all or or explainer only why not
both because the mathematicians only do
um
measurements
and then they bring an equation to the
conference they say it is an equation
yeah but that's a description yeah
because they only did half of it they
only did the the experiment part they
didn't yeah they did stuff
they did technology but I would still
put the experiment under science ends
okay anyway let me finish here with this
um in fact the critic this critic right
uh science critic admits that Hands-On
does not make you a scientist he said a
large part of my studies we're hands on
experiments right I have studied uh
computers and audio that does not make
me a scientist absolutely right you know
it doesn't make you a scientist and
these are your own words so he doesn't
understand the context because at least
on the one hand he says you need to
study and you need to do experiments I'm
saying you need to do neither neither
study nor experiments what you need to
do is explain I don't care if you
studied or not but if you can explain
something even without studying without
doing experiments you're a scientist
you're using your brain but to say you
studied you memorized the book you know
the poem and you can recite it by heart
and you can't explain anything you're
just describing you know what a tree
looks like you're beautiful in love Etc
you know that's not something aren't you
stamp collecting right now
huh when you talk about he's a scientist
he's not a scientist isn't that stamp
collector well yeah yeah we we have to
know what a scientist because because
boy my [ __ ] who is scientist because
I don't care if you're a scientist or
not can you explain what the [ __ ] I
asked what I'm saying you need to Define
what science is because we're going to
say that physics is a science we need to
know what science is first then we need
to know why physics is a science and
they have to you know if I say science
is rational explanations physics is
rational explanations of causes and
mechanisms then I have a logical
framework for you know talking about
science I was like but if people give
you two paragraphs for to Define what
science is and then another 10
paragraphs to Define what physics is
because they have all these uh
semicolons and commas and periods you
know I mean then you know we have
whatever we have what we have today
okay let's get to some of the questions
people or comments people made here's
one fellow says Bill Gatey I think it's
made of ropes ropes are made of threads
that's what I said he says but you can't
see them and he laughs well uh
I should Enlighten this poor fellow okay
and here it is quantum mechanics
everything is made of particles
particles are made of eels but you can't
see them
so he he he doesn't criticize Quantum he
doesn't criticize the fact that that
you've never seen a single particle and
then they tell you anyways that the
particle is made of fields and Fields is
a bunch of numbers and you can't see
them but he doesn't laugh at that he
said oh that's science and he says that
oh Bill you're saying that it's that you
have these uh things you call ropes or
threads or whatever and a physical
objects but you can't see them
yeah you can't see anything in Quantum
either so at least come up to speed
uh anyways
um
you can't touch them by the way okay
particles can be at two places at once
that number you never ask that question
how can to how can one particle be at
two places at once at least we don't say
that nonsense okay and fields are
numbers numbers that vibrate so uh yeah
laugh out loud there okay uh so you're
saying you have less inconsistencies
well by far I mean that is essentially
what we're saying the one weird thing
about the ropes is you can go through
them
but beyond that we don't I mean if you
stack up the inconsistencies of of
mainstream science you can make a list
that's what you do but it's not only
that it's not only that there's there's
something else it's that but there's
something else which is probably more
fundamental and that's the following we
have to imitate we have to simulate
Mother Nature's Universe Mother Nature's
universe is that if I drop the pencil
and I've done this experiment oh because
we don't have to do experiments we don't
do experiments here no no no no no we
don't do experiments and sessions that's
my point gravity we have to explain
gravity right gravity is an effect that
looks more or less like this okay uh you
let go of the pencil yeah you let go of
the pencil and it falls to the ground
now we have to explain there's nothing
here you can't see or touch what's here
or up here so whether you use the
particle whether you use the ropes it
doesn't matter you have to explain
Mother Nature's Universe in this sense
quantum mechanics is correct you can't
see or touch the mediators and gravity
yeah whether you use particles or ropes
it doesn't matter which or spirit is
anything whatever it is it's all these
people who who are asking to go into the
lab to run an experiment to see and
touch maybe because experiment is C and
touch right they're expecting to see and
touch the mediator of gravity in order
to understand you do not need to do this
you just need to visualize what physical
objects Mother Nature could be using she
could be using particles maybe pushing
down on the pencil maybe she's using
ropes to pull from below to towards the
Earth whatever you theorize no problem
but you cannot use the words see and
touch to talk about gravity light we
ruled those out and so it's obviously so
people should not be laughing when they
say oh I can't see or touch the rose
yeah of course you can't see or touch
the particles either that's almost the
so and it better be that way because
that's how Mother Nature runs it she
runs it with invisible intangible
objects hopefully now with Concepts
otherwise she's doing black magic she's
not she's not Mother Nature she's a
witch
yeah okay so here's uh another felony he
says uh Bill criticize plasma physics
oh my God some people still are
struggling with uh plasma and we define
plasma you got to look up the word I
mean I can't help you there plasma is
ionized gas essentially that's it they
have also the fourth state of matter
let's let's forget about that one plasma
is ionized gas ionized is a movie
sorry sorry to break it to you inas is a
movie gas you do not the word gas does
not embody motion you do not have to
have gas moving or the electrons moving
uh we we can have a picture like there
in a single frame of gas the you know
the the
devil again throws the entire universe
there's nothing moving you have that
picture that's a single frame that he's
got in his file cabinet we pulled it out
we say that's gas it could be air it
could be you know uh hydrofluoric and
I'm sorry
phosphine so you're saying plasma we
need a before and after yeah so so in
the case of plasma you need two frames
you can't do plasma because of the
definition of plasma you need two frames
plasma is nothing in motion do you need
something non-ionized and there's
something ionized correct
because because you need to compare it
to what it used to be if we if we go if
that's one issue you you know again uh a
concept is a relation between two things
in this case two frames before and after
okay you need to compare plasma is a
comparison it's not a thing that stands
alone if you cut the universe uh right
at time you know you have a
cross-section of time you only have
location you cannot say that's plasma
you cannot say because right now all you
have is a bunch of particles there that
are neither plasma neither gas
uh plasma requires motion the removal in
the case of the official version the
removal of an electron removal is a verb
the word remove is a verb can't you just
take the second frame of the of that
planet no because then what you're what
are you staring at that's not plasma
plasma has to be something in motion
where you're withdrawing the electron
from the atom you need to have ionize
the word ionize has to be covered in the
word plasma but again and these people
have mental problems they don't
understand that no matter how you
present it to them but like just take
the second frame there because because
it's not that's not plasma plasma is not
the second frame plasma is the two
frames the relation between the two
frames you need to remove the electron
in order removal ionized the word
ionized
and people don't understand that you
that plasma is a dynamic concept it's
not a physical Standalone object like a
tree or a stone or uh or a table
plasma means you're moving
and moving means two frames you need two
locations and two locations requires two
frames of the universal movie therefore
plasma cannot be synthesized in a
photograph into in a still frame still
image
and I don't know some people will never
the reason they don't want to understand
it is because they live their whole life
with plasma and they're stuck to plasma
and you take that God away from them you
rate their virgin hold on they're lost
if you have you know how copper against
like that weird uh turquoise look when
it gets all rusty or or tarnished yeah
that's one picture
but we still yeah so you can have
oxidized
copper as a picture but you wouldn't say
that oxidized copper is a movie
uh the transition
that because you have to have a process
of uh of oxidation yeah but when people
talk about plasma they're really just
talking like yeah I know they want to
they want to cut corners and that's what
they wanted to do until you know
oxidized copper because then you gotta
if you use oxidized oxidize the Ed yeah
but if you take a picture of it
we know we're talking we know that
that's yeah but what are you going to
call it you call it oxidized copper
oxidation yeah something happened to it
in the past hold on hold on what are you
comparing gas to a solid
no no no you don't need to go that's how
you know it's gas no no no you don't
need to compare if I look at a table
table is made out of tons of atoms gas
hold it hold it I look at the table it's
a solid right yeah it's not a gas it's
not a liquid right table or rock or how
do we know that
solids no hold it I'm just saying I'm
just saying when you get something which
is a solid any solid I don't care which
it's got atoms yeah the atoms are
vibrating right we all know that
electrons are but we're not looking at
that we're looking at the universal
movie and cutting a cross-section of
time yeah that means all we're going to
have is location nothing moves in that
frame just to make sure that people
don't start running with their heads and
say oh but the electrons move no
Foundation of all the atoms here we have
the location of everything the way the
the good old Lord or the good old how
can you tell it's a solid okay and this
is the point the point is we look at
this bunch of atoms who say that's Rock
how nobody hold it we just give it a
name it's just a name for the object we
present it and we say we're going to
call this object all these atoms that
are in contact with each other we're
going to call this object Rock okay okay
because there is no motion required in
the word Rock okay so far so good okay
solid no it doesn't matter but that's
the question what's the difference
between gas and plasma how do we know
it's a plasma it's a gas we're comparing
it to a different thing which is because
the word plasma embodies motion the word
Rock does not embody motion how can I
get this through people
good thank you but solid does
no no
not solid is not an object solid is not
a thing I know it's a category it's a
category is gas no no gases and there's
gas category and there's also gas like I
point to a bunch of atoms called air
okay inside a balloon I say gas I can
say air I can say whatever you got in
there that that bunch of uh atoms in
there yeah I do a cross-section of time
nothing is moving in there and we call
that air or gas we can call it gas or
air it doesn't matter because both are
objects but but you're comparing it to
not no because I'm not comparing the
categories gas against solid against
liquid I'm not comparing categories you
are no gas I'm saying gas like like good
point you don't know which gas it is it
could be fascinated so you say how do
you know it's a gas
body motion if there's no motion
embodied in the word gas you don't need
to have gas moving from one frame to
another gas that's not what I'm saying
but that's what I'm saying what
yeah people get so so tied up they don't
understand something straightforward not
gas is not a category I'm not using gas
as a category how are you I'm saying I'm
saying that I see a blob of of something
in the middle of space yeah okay uh the
the
the
um astronaut he blows air into a balloon
right and so we got Aaron in there in
that balloon yeah now he pops the
balloon in the middle space when there's
where there's nothing let's assume
there's absolutely stop time
uh no okay we pop the balloon you have
this blob come out of the balloon right
yeah now we stop tying okay now we have
a cross section of time so we have this
blob out there just Frozen in Time
nothing moves right we call that blob we
say well I don't know it could be air
let's go solid yeah we call it whatever
you want it's not solid solid as well
don't use the word solid okay let's call
it I see something there and I call this
gas let's call it excellent no but I can
call it gas it's a generic term for any
uh gas it could be a category no that's
what you just said it could be a generic
term for anything I can call it gas I
can call it gas when you say I smell gas
you don't know which gas it is it
doesn't matter because you just say gas
I point to and say gas but that's a
category no you can't no I can't
separate the category no I can call the
word I can use the word gas to refer to
a thing as well as a category I can use
it as both but you're talking about a
group of animals when I see liquid
liquid is a category right but I can say
you know milk or or whatever I I don't
know which one that is but I can tell
the E.T liquid yeah and he looks at this
blob and he knows okay that's liquid the
word liquid refers to that blob that
river that ocean whatever is there yeah
so you called it liquid you can't do
that with with plasma because you're not
talking about you're not talking about
something that is static you cannot
point to plasma you cannot point to
ground you can point to liquid you can
point to gas and you can point not to
solid because there is no thing called
solid cannot be used as a thing whereas
gas and liquid can be used as things as
well as categories
anyways the point here is that plasma
requires motion okay requesting gas is
not yeah I don't need to have motion to
for for any gas I can have a blob a
bunch of atoms and call it gas that word
is acceptable plasma you need to have
Motion in there you have to have
ionization and until people get that
through their thick skulls you know it's
going to be forever uh the discussion
penetrate where things go yeah
okay another file says objects fields
and energies have shapes and physical
presence fields and energies aren't
objects well this fell uh in the past
said the opposite he said that uh fields
and energy are objects okay so it's very
difficult to someone who's inconsistent
that's the first issue but then what is
the shape of a magnetic field
I mean is that that's a field that's
that's what you see for Fields what is
the shape of that you know where does it
begin where does it end uh are those
arrows what are those uh you know
engineeros what and then what is the
shape of energy
okay so again uh no fields and energy
and energy uh their Concepts they're not
physical objects Standalone objects
there's no physical object called Energy
okay in fact uh it's got many
definitions because of that because you
can't point to energy you can't point to
field okay a field is a concept that
says many values you know are in space
huh we just got numbers yeah values it's
just numbers with units you know
yeah
uh someone says is a thought object an
object
uh the word tree does not necessarily
imply the existence in itself of the
thing thought in other cases
however it indicates a reality that has
its own existence
independent of the knowledge or idea
that the thinking object may have of it
the single word is not good if used to
define a precise concept so he proposes
using two words right adjective
um in front of a noun right the solution
is to use at least two words such as
real object real thing I don't realize
yeah so so we have a solution for this
fellow we have a good solution here and
it is uh well first of all yeah he has
the same notion that uh human can't had
and they just like this uh they confused
existence with object that's that's the
issue the idea of exists according to
him the idea of existence then is the
very same with the idea of what we can
uh conceive to be existent okay the idea
when conjoined with the idea of any
object makes no addition to it whatever
we can see we conceive to be existent in
other words according to Hume an object
in existence were synonyms because you
add Nothing by saying that it exists to
the word object that was his notion and
cancer is more or less the same thing he
came a few years later but he said the
same thing says buy whatever and buy
however many predicates I may think a
thing even in completely determining it
nothing is really added to it if I add
that the thing exists so they couldn't
tell the difference between thing and
existence and this is this is our answer
okay
um
[Laughter]
[Applause]
cover that one later
okay this is the answer uh idiot
individual who has big
etymology from the ancient Klingon idea
plus Ott you know he doesn't have little
ideas he says idea UTS and an idiot is
someone who confuses object with exist
okay so we got that uh anyone who talks
about existence in the context of the
definition of the word object uh well
the Klingon says he's an idiot okay and
so
um make sure you know where you stand on
that
okay and uh I think it's the same file
he continues he says something here he
says the sequence in defining words is
uh fundamental absolutely and this is
what he didn't understand he said it but
he didn't understand what he said
we must define object before we Define
exist because you can't have exist only
because and there you see it only
objects can be said to exist why because
object is that which has shaped distance
as we covered today separation between
objects location is the set of distances
and just now we can start defining the
word exist which is what object that has
location this kind of reminds me of
programs
in programming they also have something
called dependencies yeah or something
you know it depends on the previous
thing so you need to finish that
previous thing before you continue
because if you did not Define that thing
what would happen
right you can the system doesn't know
what to do yeah you have to define
something if it's the if it's the
precondition for another word exactly
and I mean if you find the word object
in the word exists then you have to
Define an object before you define
exists right and otherwise otherwise you
have to define the word exists and tell
us what you mean by and I guess the
bucks if you can Define it with the
without the word the buck stops is shape
uh yeah at shape no sorry before shape
an object because shape is that we point
to right
yeah object object is that what you can
put shape is like an adjective no it's
like an adjective it's like a a uh a um
attribute of an object it's a universal
attribute of all objects right you know
every object yeah but but you would say
that you don't really have to Define
shape that's one that's like come on
yeah at that point it's like well what
are we doing here no let me tell you why
you don't have to Define shape and
that's got to do with a totally
different context it's got to do with
the fact that everybody wants to
introduce C and touch and so all we're
doing is comparing shape against C and
touch
so and it's not it's that shape and see
and touch are irrational you need two
objects to do c and touch you don't need
uh another object to to uh have the
notion of shape so and every object has
shape not every object can be seen and
touch and so on and so forth but don't
you need eyes to see a shape yeah which
is what are your eyes
are they things okay so uh here's uh the
answer to this well also uh mental
images right or imaginary objects are
objects that don't exist so the table
that you have in your mind that one
doesn't exist because it doesn't have
location it's an object because the word
table is anachi so if I'm thinking of
table I'm already thinking of an object
but the object doesn't exist because
that table does not have location that
would be but all tables the word table
always represents an object the fact
that some exist because they have
location others don't because they don't
have location that's what separates
objects that exist from those that don't
exist that would be a big difference
between you and humankind because they
would say that all table Levels by
definition exists well they are objects
they never thought about the Klingons
table that they can't see your touch
anyways uh the table I put uh here my my
beer mug on is an object okay that we're
talking about a real one there right and
this table has location and therefore
exists the table I'm imagining is an
object right because the word table
always refers to an object the table I'm
imagining does not have location
therefore the table I'm imagining does
not exist because it does not have
location
and with that I will see you oh we got
two more questions oh that I I memorized
them oh okay yeah one was uh how can you
say we're the last generation on Earth
with your progeny sitting next to you
I'm gonna kill him sometimes I want to
go now uh the word generation you know I
mean look at look at the following
example Newton was born on the year in
the year that uh Galileo died where they
of the same generation
I mean they they both lived in the 17th
century uh one died in 1642 the other
guy was born in 1642. and so the
question is you know were they of the
same generation what do we call a
generation uh the hundred year period is
that a generation it should be called a
20-year period and all I can tell you is
the word generation cannot be perfectly
fine
I got one okay uh how old is the oldest
person
that's the generation uh he just died
yeah but but let's just give it a number
assuming right now the oldest living
person is 104 years old I'd say that is
the generation until that person dies
well there's everything before that
person's time is that is by definition
history no because let me tell you
there's another way of looking at it you
can say generation is people who dress
the same uh you can say Generations
people who thought the same or had the
same ideas there's a different ways of
categorizing generation like you say the
90s generation like all these people
thought the same way or they like the
same music or whatever you cannot Define
generation or there are many contests
isn't that easier the last group of
humans yeah I guess you can use any word
my point here is that Extinction is
imminent okay and yeah that includes
my dear son here one of my dear Sons I
got three sons the other question was
the common one uh is is space an object
well uh we have to define space and
objects and they are different in other
words uh let's put in in better terms so
that you can see the difference one is
called something and the other thing is
called and the other one is called
Nothing something hopefully is the
opposite of nothing
something that which I shape nothing
that which doesn't happen sounds like
kindergarten yeah it is it is it's
kindergarten and now we can use these
words consistently in any discussion
because you say something and people say
oh I know what that is that's that which
I see what is nothing that which doesn't
have shade and it's the opposite they're
antonyms so it's perfect now you can use
these words but to say you know that
which I can see your touch well can you
see your touch space yeah well if you
leave it up to the mathematician they
take our fields in there we can see or
touch them can you say that you're
seeing space because it's black right I
don't know what you do no no because if
there were no objects you would not see
anything you would say I see black but
what do you say
I'm blind I see space no Bobby you're
vlogging I'm not seeing what you see is
the moon you see Jupiter and you say
well here's the moon here's Jupiter
what's in between we'll call it that
black guy out of this thing I see his
face no you're blind but
that's it okay we'll see you with that
next oh a lot of people talking about uh
one more no no what was it
calculating for mass in E equals MC
squared that was a huge debate here
going on yeah
there's people involved with this Eagles
emcee all I can tell you is uh I discuss
E equals m c squared in the past and
just synthesizing so when you we don't
stretch it that much
um energy is a concept mass is a concept
and little C is also a concept it's just
the speed okay so so all we have is in
mathematics all you have is Concepts and
there are numbers followed by units
that's all we have there well you can
the question the question the question
from a physical point of view which is
what we're interested to hear is what
does any what are we referring to when
we talk about energy mass and velocity
of light Square how can we uh convert
these in some physicality that we can
all relate to that we can all visualize
that's where we need the issue and the
uh you know again to synthesize I'm not
going to go to all the details but I'm
saying that light travels from one atom
to another and back again and others the
other atom also sends light to this atom
because all atoms are interconnected
that's your c squared because means
light travels in both directions and to
every atom in the universe and every
atom in the universe sends light to our
atom our our Target atom here and so
that's the c squared Mass uh as I've
shown in the past is the mass of the
hydrogen atom because it is the minimum
uh entity where you have something in
the universe that's the unit of mass the
hydrogen atom everything else Springs
from there and so you have the hydrogen
atom and the velocity of light squared
and if you can find the video there in
somewhere you'll find more details on
that but that's essentially I didn't
realize until you just said it but no
matter what calculation you're doing in
math you're always using Concepts yeah
you can't do math with objects you're
either using the length of the object
the speed of the object it's not the
length it's the color measurement the
distance right by your tape yeah it's
always
yeah it's all it's all Concepts in math
and that's why unless they put some
physicality to it uh it's irrelevant but
more important than that the reason they
had to give physical interpretations to
that is that otherwise the math would be
irrelevant yeah no one would care nobody
would care okay folks with that we'll
see you next week thanks for tuning in